[Musik]
heute gibt's bei mir ein paar tief lag
mit fluchtgefahr und zwar sind das wort
dort ummantelt mit kartoffeln und käse
zu verleger und ich zeige euch jetzt
gleich die flut haben wir benötigen weg
führt ihn die ich bereits viermal
durchgeschnitten haben 1,2 kilogramm
kartoffeln die habe ich gekocht und
anschließend geschält 60 kamel 150 gramm
käse und einer telefon egal ob für den
mantel der häppchen wert als allererstes
die kartoffeln weiterverarbeitet die
werden einfach in eine große schüssel
geblieben
[Musik]
dazu wird dann das original gegeben
der käse unterziehen und dadurch dass
die tiere schon deutlich genug ist wird
auch alec format verwendet wenn die
masse dann mit den händen schön
verknetet wurde dann habt ihr einen
kompakten und leicht klebrige mit hilfe
meines großen sports in ihrer stelle ich
mir da etwas vom teig ab und gebe dann
ein system vereint das wissen wir jetzt
sagen einmal umschlossen ein bisschen
geformt und wenn ihr dann friedewald
gibt das ganze auf einen teller
[Musik]
die mengenangaben vom zeit wie passen
übrigens ganz genau auf 24 fuß gehen und
wenn ihr dann eine packung mit 614 kauf
gibt's ja meistens mit sechs stück und
die dann durch viel teil dann habt ihr
ja auch genau 24 will voraus und wenn
dann alle häppchen schön geformt sind
kommen die für 30 minuten ins
gefrierfach zufolge sie dann im öl
auftraten das öl in einer pfanne habe
ich bereits erhebt und wenn wir in
hollstadt freitod und bisschen
aufsteigen dann ist genau richtig
jetzt werden die hot dog edwin darin weg
ab zweieinhalb minuten lang zitiert
meine erste ladung habe ich vielleicht
eine halbe minute zu lange drin gehabt
und deswegen bis hin zu dunkel geworden
aber danach immer genau zweieinhalb
minuten und dann habt ihr das perfekte
ergebnis
wenn wir dann alle häppchen nacheinander
aufgebrachten habt dann könnt ihr auch
schon servieren und nimmt einfach euren
lieblingen klose neuen lieblings ketchup
und dann nach dem schmecken und ich
wünsche euch ganz viel spaß dann
nachmachen
soll ich mich jetzt verabschiede mich
noch ganz herzlich eine liebe
zuschauerin grüßen und zwar die chance
seine liebe für dich hier mit camp
herzlich und ich bin so froh dass du
immer so fleißig in die kommentare
schreiben
für mehr rezepte auch das abonnieren
nicht vergessen und bis zum nächsten mal
auf die skizzen